all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today we are here with
episode number 13 of noob with a mill so
if you guys haven't checked out the
series before and don't really know
what's going on basically at one point I
was a relative Noob I think I had
probably around 600 700 total level and
I had a mill that I was given from my
other account small loan of a million
dollars and now but now I've turned it
into about 175 mil and I'm going to go
ahead and show you guys what I got going
on on the grand what I got going on in
my grand exchange real quick all right
so as you guys can see here I've been
selling off Ferro scepter charge for
about
7.95 so I'm going to try to buy them as
you guys can see I sold off one for this
price but I upped it by 1 GP cuz I'm a
[__] scumbag but if I charge these
that's a 315k margin but these are going
to take forever to buy so we're going to
have to figure out something else to do
while I wait I think I'm going to go and
edit my last video so we're going to
figure out something pretty AFK to do
all right there we are so finished off
our cave Horrors task going to go ahead
and get another assignment 135 black
demons sounds like I'm not about to do
that right now and we are back so went
ahead and sold off a bunch of Ferro
scepter you guys can't really tell what
price I was able to sell them on at but
take my word for it I sold them all for
about 150k profit and so that was a cool
1.5 mil right there um still waiting for
some odium chart TW to buy so I can
finish up these Wards but also made 100
can some eclectics and was able to buy
even some more so we're going to go
ahead and sell these off should be able
to make
another like 130 to 150k there and yeah
that's about it so doing a stream right
now if you guys have never checked out
my stream before make sure to go check
it out it'll be in the description down
below but I was recently merching a
collec as you guys saw and just decided
that I'm going to go ahead and do some
clue Scrolls so get ready for that we
have 2.6k I don't know how many I'm
going to do hopefully I don't get too
unlucky though so let's get into it clue
number one coming in and nothing medium
clue number
two okay I mean it's a unique I guess
but not what we're looking for also by
the way it took me 85 a colle ICS almost
to get that clue that is [__]
finishing clue number three purple
sweets hey it's something it's something
another
one well we got a page it's a sidan page
so it's not worth [__] but it's a page
another one oh hey hey Sam Saran merer
that was I think that was a little that
was a little high on the on the oo but I
was I was pretty happy I think Zam
Rock's probably worth a decent amount
not as happy now but still it's a it's
something different I'll just let Rick
Ross say it another one boom Oh my God
not very high hopes for this one band's
cloak all right I mean I'll take it hell
yeah another clue all right all right I
mean that's that's all right I guess
gold trim that looks sick boom okay well
uh some sweets I guess we'll call it a
win and uh yeah I just figure it goes
without saying at this point wo we got
it a
god another clue done there we go so o
two zamrock miters and a [__] red
headband what the [__] what the [__]
hell yeah all right for anyone that
thinks that I wasn't actually going to
give away the bond from the uh dust
devil video there you go he wanton it in
cash
2,900,000 wait is that it is that
right 2.9 mil to that guy there you go
there you go congratulations to that guy
though all right so first clip of postc
in the episode couple Ferro sors charges
made 115k off of each and two odium w
made 300K off of both and just finish
off my black demon task so going to go
ahead and get another one Bandos are you
kidding oh God I don't know how many I
could get [__] I'm just going to cancel
this God I wish I could I mean it
probably makes sense to go ahead and do
a trip but I'm not about it I can get my
herb sack here soon so whatever greater
demons there we go greater demons task
done going to go ahead and get another
task Kalisto yes baby hell yeah 35 I'll
take it I'll kill all of them [__] it
wanted to go ahead and invest overnight
so as you guys can see I sold off an
ancestral hat for 1.7 mil margin uh
probably could have sold off for about
1.9 to 2 mil but I figured investing in
these Ferro spors or not really
investing but as much as kind of
flipping them would be more to my
benefit than just sitting here and doing
nothing with the money so uh I mean the
the extra 200k I would have made is
relatively nothing compared to if I'm
able to actually utilize this money uh
we'll see how that goes though I'm going
to go ahead and leave this offer in so
that should be 13 Ferro sors overnight
hopefully well I don't know if this is
good or bad Ferro sors have gone up a
ton lately and overnight I was able to
buy all of them for 7.7 mil usually it's
a better to see that you can't buy them
all CU then that means they're at least
above the price that you bought them at
but this is a little scary I have to go
ahead and sell off some eclectics to
find out if I'm if I'm going to lose mad
amount of money uh I could definitely
make money still but I'm not feeling all
that confident about it right now all
right this is all the money I have right
now 7.9 mil uh I'm going to go ahead and
see if I can buy a Ferro sceptor for
that um if I can't that's really nice
and I'll be really excited I think that
was my phone vibrating because it was
turning on if I can't buy one I'll
actually be pretty happy but I think I'm
going to be able to yeah seven okay okay
we can work with that
7875 that would be 175k profit per nice
nice all right so that's like 2.1 2.2
mil all right I gotta end this clip my
phone's just gonna keep going off all
right so after trying to do Kalisto for
a ton of times I ended up getting pked
like almost every other kill so I ended
up canceling that task went ahead and
got 90 Anu so from there went ahead and
canceled another task after the anku
task and ended up getting hellhounds y
here we go just woke up got to put in my
P and all right the price is exactly the
same as it was last night that's really
weird but that's pretty good that'd be
190k profit off each a little over 2 mil
I had no clue that this was like a
5-minute Quest but went ahead and did
Elemental Workshop one apparently two is
only like a 10-minute Quest so I may as
well just go and do that now so that's
another Quest Point moving on up oh my
God kill me I finished the [__] Quest
I had the [__] bar and then I picked
the wrong [__] one Apparently one of
these which is this one crafts a [__]
Helmet or some [__] and this one crafts
a [__] Shield why do that why do that
game why [__] just have an option
down here where I can click which one I
[__] want God that's [__] idiot
and now I just got to [__] redo this
part I mean they practically whole
[__] Quest just to say [__] this I'm
out I'm complete my [__] clue scroll
what I came here for not none of this
[__] got ourselves a casket so this is
the first hard clue that I've done in a
while but going to go ahead see what we
get and Gothic page not too bad 60k
we'll take it all right so after that
ended up going back to do some Slayer I
ended up getting a Jad task which was
really nice um I also merched a third
age plate body in between and I made 1.7
mil off of that so that was a huge merge
for the video um from there went ahead
and did Jad didn't get my best time yet
but obviously brings us up to 5 KC there
uh 25k Slayer XP so I was really happy
about that go ahead and gamble the cape
and uh yeah nothing from that so from
there went ahead and went on a little
bit of a Slayer grind so I mean as far
as Slayer task go I don't want to
commentate over all of them kind of gets
repetitive I feel like but it is kind of
important to the account as you guys get
to see the progress that I go through
and kind of the loot that I get by my
inventory one thing I've noticed though
is I'm really really unlucky when it
come to C when it comes to Cave Horrors
um I'm probably closing in on 8 to 900
and haven't gotten a black mask yes yet
which would have been really nice uh
other than that though I mean kind of
happened on my main account usually it
starts to even out after a while so I'm
hoping uh finish off a kbd Tas back
there which uh unluckily enough we
didn't get a whole lot we did get two
kbd heads though which was pretty cool
but yeah that's about it haven't
recorded a live clip in a while but this
is a merch I'm doing so last night I
bought on a ton of feros sors for 736
and I'm selling them all for like an 80
to 90k profit uh I was hoping I'd make a
little more but that's still a little
over a m like 1.3 to 1.4 um on top of
that been merching some uh dragon fire
Shields as you guys can see made 140k on
that one another 140k and so in total I
probably made like 600k off of them I
got another two bu right now but I got
to go to class and uh yeah I don't think
this margin is going to be here whenever
I get back so that's the last one I'm
going to merge I'm going to keep this
one for the wyvern T that I have that
moment when you go to use a dragon f
Shield but you're not 75 defense and you
kind of hate yourself a little bit back
again with the postc com so after my
wyvern's Tas went ahead and got fire
Giants not a bad task um I'm kind of
debating on whether or not I should do
them in the catacombs or in ne's cave
but uh yeah went ahead and got the
Flames of zamok spell completed I just
had to go and cast 200 times I figured
it may be needed for a diary or
something I haven't looked over it but I
figured I had the runes I was making a
guide on it so I may as well uh from
there just go ahead and kill some anku
and blood felds uh this is kind of the
first time I bought a lot of cannon
balls I actually had a time earlier in
the series where I made enough money off
of green drags and cannoning them to get
about 25k so buying all those back kind
of made up for it from there go ahead
and get a black demon task and then a
fire Giants uh from there dust devils
which is obviously really nice get some
barraging done but here I made a ton of
money off some Ferro scepter about 150k
each so 2.2 mil another dust Devil's
task are done so uh no superiors which
is pretty rough but some decent Mage XP
uh 23k away from n or 80 definitely have
to work on that but 150 cave fores nice
and AFK hopefully hit a black mask I
think that'd be the first one of this
account finish the k for task again no
black MK surprisingly enough 144 Cal
fights something easy that I can just
Canon real quick and be over with nice
here we go finish off the Cal fights
task so another task Cal fight Queen oh
God can I even I don't know if I'd be
able to even do Cal fight queen that
well go with three and just see what we
can do I lied I thought about it more
don't want to try and do that next task
suas we'll take it and suaz task is done
so I have a ton of reward points that I
can now use so I'm going to go ahead and
get myself an herb sack this is pretty
big since uh you know 750 points spent
better be on something nice and uh time
to get another task cave horse God damn
man and I know it's we're damn well not
going to get a [__] black mask either
finished off Cave horse surprisingly
enough no black mask 161 Cal fights
again I mean it's quick task I guess but
kind of blows all right another Cal
fights task done done so time to get
another task iron dragons this one take
a while I I cannot stand them boom nice
and easy finish off the iron dragons let
me get out of here God damn it there we
go all right so very close to 96
strength 100K away that's obviously
going to be the first 99 of this account
so 164 Abby specs I haven't had those in
a while and herbs set coming in clutch
right away so I think that's where we're
going to end off the video I don't know
if I have anything in my grand exchange
I have to go and collect real quick I do
indeed so I'm to throw everything in the
bank and we'll finish this up uh OS
buddy actually has a week of Premium
stuff so I don't have to switch clients
which is really nice but I'll be back
here in a second all right here we are
ready to go so going to go ahead and do
a price check on the bank as you guys
saw a second ago 24K impling so we kind
of need to get that in uh one thing I am
going to do though real quick empty out
my room pouch because I know that that
has a lot um so let me find it all right
so we emptied out everything that was
going to be like another Mill to two mil
in there so I had to make sure I got
that but let's go ahead and do it now so
go on over to price Checker let me do
this real quick so here we are go to
calculate
and
195.000 mil so pretty much 196 mil not
too bad at all we've come a long way on
this account about to hit the 200 mil
Mark which is going to be lit um in the
next video I look forward to just kind
of progressing this account a little
more more towards Zora I definitely need
to get my Mage and range up and maybe
start working on voyd but that'll be it
for me today hopefully you guys enjoyed
if you guys did make sure to hit that
like button anything you guys want me to
do on the account or anything you guys
want to see in the future make sure to
comment comment down below you guys
really enjoy my content hit that sub
button and uh yeah nonetheless with that
being said hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace
[Music]